Georgiy you did an excellent job playing
Beth Anderson perfect sisters tell us
who is Beth Beth is almost like one half
of the same person she's you know she
couldn't be any closer to her sister
Sandra
but they've brave had a very difficult
childhood they've moved around their
mother has been a struggling alcoholic
and they've had to deal with a string of
abusive boyfriend so when we first see
Beth she's vulnerable and just trying to
hold everything together and hold
herself together and her sister together
right and some would say that maybe she
was more of the darker sister in some
sense but in many ways she had some
strong qualities that you see during the
film how much of your own personality
did you bring to her and how much of
Beth is nothing like you I think Beth's
strengths I could only dream of having I
mean the inner strength that she finds
when her sister begins to crumble is you
know admire Ville and but I definitely
could relate to her her vulnerability
because you know at times we all face
challenges and that was something that I
really wanted to kind of show that you
know she's constantly trying to overcome
things and you know for me as a person
I've never had to overcome anything like
Beth but we've all faced challenges that
we've had to deal with so that was
probably something that I could that I
can relate to and also she has a massive
capacity for fun you know her and Sandra
constantly you know just wanting to have
fun and escape into this fantasy land
and you know that's something I can
definitely definitely relate to well
there's a very real chance that all
three siblings could see the film and
your interviews what would you want the
real Beth I know her name's been changed
once released from prison to take away
from your performance that's a very
interesting question I think I would
just not want her to be upset in any way
by the film as long as she would be able
to watch it and feel any kind of feeling
you know Rach except for you know
sadness you know I wouldn't want to
upset her and that's certainly not what
I set out to do I set out to do a film
not a documentary I never read the book
by Bob Mitchell and I made a conscious
decision not to do that so that I was
taking my cues only from the script and
only from the character I saw in the
script so yeah
you